[Applaudissements]
la solution
[Musique]
plus je me réveille et quand je regarde le
terrain d'accord
J'ai déjà tout trouvé dans ta main
dans ma main
on s'évade de tout ensemble on voit le soleil se coucher
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va à la plage pour soigner l'âme
fermer l'écran ouvrir la médaille tout
la mer des caraïbes regarde ta taille
vous loin qu'elle veut très bien paraître
J'aime ça lentement et avec ça
[Musique]
au bien parce qu'il profite du fait qu'il libère un
ligne de stockage pour entrer dans le
de l'eau pour que vous puissiez voir à quel point c'est délicieux et
meunier et tropical avec la côte historique
de hamacs hamac à aimer
un peu un mauvais coup de sangria
pour que le rêve
et aussi découragé parce qu'il va hésiter non
vous devez devenir un homme riche et lui donner
lent
beaucoup de coquito et comme nous sommes allés à
sauvez-le doucement pour qu'il vous libère
petit à petit car il ne faut pas hésiter
nous devons les faire mourir à l'étage, nous allons
la plage pour guérir l'âme ferme le
l'écran ouvre toute la mer des caraïbes en regardant
ta taille t'éloigne qui veut te chercher
une mère
le plus dur de l'âme combien d'heures
si tu flirtes avec un importateur et qu'il me cherche
sur tout le continent et consensus
se porter bien
Je suis comme le visage rouge
et laisse l'esprit hellénique le violer
ferme ça pour qu'ils puissent me sortir du corps
le télétravail c'est dur c'est dans
bouge la moustache je dis que nous devons
vent et donne-le-moi, il a ma taille, il me tue
compté le muscle regarde comment je gère
parce qu'il sait qu'il l'est et maintenant il me calme
la vie sereinement kim s'impose sans tant
marcher tranquillement dans ma vie
Calmer
ciel nous avons dansé pour la plage
guéris ton âme ferme l'écran ouvert
la médaille dans toute la mer des caraïbes étant toi
taille
tu as flirté avec lui tu cherches
[Musique]
retournons
à présent
voir ta taille loin ça te coûte
dur
danse portoricaine
excuse moi oui noriega
ils ont versé la bonne eau
pareil avec la vérité
[Applaudissements]